the show is getting very deservedly
recognized tonight how are you gonna
feel in there if you guys take home a
few sets I'll feel great today I'm sure
I won't feel to crash water in the
morning no it'd be lovely gold why can't
we expect coming up next on the show I
know they keep it under lock and key but
do you know anything it's so far under
lock and key that I don't think they
even know like we've heard of radical
shift is coming if they changed your
family did they did they watch the show
how big of fans are they they do they're
not my mommy's religious she's a bride
some sort of bride in terms of the
brothers they're pretty slack
you have that brotherhood that
competition could you ever get them on
the show I don't think they have the
attention span
[Music]
you know what you're the one at the
Emmys right
exactly like that take that but really
how have you guys talked about like once
I mean 21 nominations I think you've got
that's nuts like how does everybody feel
just being here all right awesome
hey like I said you know it's nice to
get a little more doctor I hold up my
side tiny sweat blood tears incredible
kratom
Aaron Paul joining how did everybody
feel about that right yeah dream on if
the brothers are too
Jim for the show could we see you guys
do a project together anytime soon Melek
we don't ever get all three of you on
screen together i website one day yeah
it's just a matter of finding the right
thing and join me
I'm making sure that your brothers
engaged what are they just gonna do it
when is that wedding just gonna happen
are
how do you do it are you both best man's
do you do multiple best
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]